une scène un public et 12 minutes pour
présenter une thèse de plusieurs années
le phénomène universel télex investi ce
mercredi 30 novembre le dff l'ap de
palaiseau cet événement était organisé
pour la deuxième année consécutive par
paris saclay en partenariat avec saint
quentin en yvelines
cette année douze intervenants
participer à ce rendez-vous dans les
profils il ya un peu de tout en fait il
ya le premier c'est un scientifique qui
est aussi philosophe il ya thierry marx
qui est un chef étoilé mais c'est vrai
un quelqu'un qui s'est fait par lui même
c'est un parcours personnel
donc en fait il ya des chercheurs
entrepreneurs artistes et des
aventuriers comme avec ghislain bardot
pour un des deux pôles le thème retenu
au delà des limites
une problématique qui attiré plus de 600
spectateurs dans la salle
au delà des limites c'est un suivi
effectué manqué à fait c'est assez large
et très intéressant yves et la diversité
dans les intervenants et il est
l'événement est également retransmis en
direct dans dix sites de la région
parisienne dans les yvelines une
retransmission était programmée à
l'école d'ingénieurs estaca de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pouvoir y
aller comme ça en plus près juste après
les cours c'est très pratique et comme
jeu
j'aime particulièrement les conférences
tedx je suis content de pouvoir revenir
à l'estaca aujourd'hui le télex saclay
reviendra pour une troisième édition
l'année prochaine l'événement sera cette
fois-ci organisée à l'école d'ingénieurs
centrale supélec dans les hauts-de-seine
le thème a déjà été dévoilé les
intervenants devront plancher sur le
service du vivant